[Music]
my name is maria and i'm going to walk
you through on how i restore my barbies
playing
[Music]
what makes this plane very special is
that they don't do more of these planes
anymore
so it's an old plane that's 21 years old
the plane was in really bad conditions
the first thing i'm gonna clean is the
inside of the plane
the color of the plane was originally
blue but you can tell there's some
yellowish around because it's too old
the best way to clean the plane it will
be
doing circular motion with the
toothbrush that way everything it starts
to come up and because i'm using the
dish soap if there's something greasy on
the plane it's gonna take it out
[Music]
the biggest issue with restoring this
plane are the stickers because you can
barely see what is on them
for removing the stickers i'm gonna use
this red spatula that is made of plastic
silicon
and very gently i'm gonna go through
like the windows and
all the parts that have secret residue
it's extremely important that we remove
completely every residue if not the
primer will not stick well
and we're gonna see painting of the
primer like breaking and then
not even the sandpaper is gonna take
that out so we have to be very very
careful in this part
[Music]
after cleaning and removing all the
stickers it's very important to put this
primer before the spray paint because
this is gonna let the other paint just
stick much better
we don't want to spray a lot of layers
on the plane otherwise it wouldn't like
open well or track well we're just gonna
put two coats one the primer and then
the spray paint
[Music]
the reason why i chose this spray paint
is because it sticks very well on the
plastic
the spray technique it's pretty much
just going from the far never close and
from left to right very patient so it
doesn't drip
the plane originally is made of plastic
and it has no paint the plastic was
originally blue so it was a challenge
because it's not gonna be like 100
how it was before but it's gonna be very
very close
for the
pink chairs i'm gonna mix two colors uh
white and red and then i'm going to put
it in an airbrusher so i can spray them
all around
[Music]
is going to take me most of the time is
actually doing or rebuilding the
stickers
i was trying to find the stickers
everywhere websites internet and i
couldn't find anything so that's why i
decided to do it by myself i had to
print them in two different papers the
first it's gonna be on a white
background that was very useful for the
stickers that were on the windows the
ones in the tail that have like the
barbie logo and everything and then for
the flowers because the blue behind the
flowers was
the original blue it was really hard to
match the spray paint that i that i used
so i just went through transparent
background so you can see the flowers
but you can also see through them and
see like this beautiful new
blue from the spray paint
to remember uh how or where to put all
these stickers and not to miss anything
i want to say i looked to the pictures
and i made my research but honestly i
played so much with this playing that it
was all in my mind and i knew exactly
which stickers i had to make or
where to put them
[Music]
you